[Applaudissements]
merci bonsoir
le face à face sera bientôt avec des
machines qu'on appelle des robots qu'est
ce que c'est qu'un robot c'est une
machine à au moins trois fonctionnalités
qui va percevoir son environnement elle
le perçoit grâce à des caméras grâce à
des micros grâce à des censeurs et puis
grâce à ses différentes captures de
signaux cette machine va prendre des
décisions et va enfin actionné ses bras
ou ses jambes et faire des actions en
tout cas dans notre vie réelle un robot
c'est pas la même chose que ce qu'on
appelait un robot dans les années 50
c'est tout sauf déterministe puisque il
a une perception de l'environnement
il peut faire des choses qui n'étaient
pas prévues ou qui n'étaient pas
directement liées en fait qu'ils
n'étaient pas programmés comme cela
alors qu'est ce qu'on met dans ses
robots mais beaucoup de modules
d'intelligence artificielle alors
l'intelligence artificielle c'est un
oxymore intelligence et de l'humain est
artificielle c'est l'artt et faxer de la
machine je parle souvent d'imitation
artificielle et on a développé
énormément d'anxiété autour de ces
robots qui vont prendre notre travail
qui vont arriver autour de nous pour
différentes tâches alors c'est vrai que
les premiers robots sont là pour nous
aider pour des tâches qui sont
difficiles pénible etc
les robots qu'on est en train de faire
en ce moment sont plutôt sur des tâches
intellectuelles et on va même jusqu'à
des robots qui pourraient faire de
l'interaction sociale avec nous et donc
détecter nos émotions et être dans cet
univers j'ai mis ici en fait ce qui
génère aussi de l'anxiété chez nous se
sont tous cet environnement de science
fiction qui a précédé en fait la
robotique
le mot robot il a été prononcé la
première fois dans une pièce de théâtre
qui était donné en 1920 et donc le
scénario des faits par cas rappelle et
le mot robot vient de re botha serviteur
esclaves qui vient donc du slave
on a vu différents films qui marquent
les esprits qui font que on a
l'impression que ces machines vont être
très intelligente vont avoir une
conscience vont avoir des émotions si
vous rappeler le film heures par exemple
qu'on voit en bas la personne s'attache
à une machine
et la machine s'attache à l'humain aussi
et d'un seul coup dans le film ya un
point essentiel car et vous la machine
dit qu'elle est amoureuse de x milliers
de personnes hier soir l'aca une espèce
de rupture de dissymétrie et l'humain se
dit bon là qu'est ce que c'est que cette
relation réelle human c'était
intéressant aussi c'est une série
télévisée donc en suède
envoyer des robots dans différents
utilité dans la vie de tous les jours
que ce soit pour aider les enfants pour
leurs devoirs ou pour aider des
personnes âgées ou encore comme robot
sexuel
on va voir de plus en plus ces images
autour de nous est-ce qu'on est encore
dans la fiction ou pas j'avais mis aussi
l'image de all donc de cette
intelligence artificielle embarqué dans
un vaisseau qui parlait qui à la fin
quand la personne le débranche dit je
sens ma conscience s'en aller mais il
est donc cette émotion sont derrière
tous ces machines sacré de l'anxiété
aussi les mutants crée aussi un derrière
on à frankenstein qui était donc et le
golem ont fait des robots ont fait ces
machines qui d'un seul coup deviennent
des machines qui ont des intentions et
qui nous aident et qui vont se rebeller
contre leurs créateurs
alors qu'est ce qu'on va trouver dans la
société à l'heure actuelle ce sont des
robots qui sont soit alors on appelle
normalement un robot s'il ya un objet
qui va se mouiller qui va bouger mais on
a tendance à parler de robots aussi pour
des logiciels les tchats botte c'est
l'agent conversationnel sont par exemple
c'est google home alexa amazon je ne
sais pas si vous en avez en tout cas aux
états unis ça se développe et dans les
moyens des foyers il ya si vous
guilhaumon voyez un par pièce ça prend
une importance incroyable
on va voir différents sortes de machines
apparaît donc c'est multiforme et aussi
des robots qui nous copient beaucoup d'e
on appelle ça des geminoid des jumeaux
robotique de nous mêmes comme le
professeur ishiguro avec son jumeau
robotique on voit dans l'image en eau et
donc ces machines qui essaient de nous
ressembler elles vont porter confusion
est d'autant plus que lorsque cette
machine s'adresse à nous nous dit
quelque chose avec un peu d'empathie
même si c'est de la fec en pâtit eh bien
on va te voir tendance à anthropomorphes
ise a prêté à ces machines des capacités
humaines
bon je vous dire j'ai écrit un livre qui
s'appelle des robots des hommes mythe
fantasme et réalité
j'ai eu à répondre des courriers des
lecteurs et des lectrices et des
lecteurs et j'ai une dame qui me disait
moi j'ai un robot chez moi c'est un
robot aspirateur
quand ils s'arrêtent au milieu de son
salon mais que pense-t-il j'ai pas
imaginer une réponse satisfaisante sans
doute mais voyez le niveau en fait
de culture sur ces machines et de
compréhension sur la chine a besoin
d'être renforcée progressivement ton
profil émotionnel et adapter nos
comportements
pis tu ne parleras et puis le gros qu'il
se stabilisera d'accord c'est une bonne
nouvelle fait ramasser son pouvoir
jordan et moi s'est satisfait aussi
expansif et qui arrivent à se poser
jacques était donc comporter mon avis
tant que je fais dans mon laboratoire où
travaillent sur la tessiture de la voix
la prosodie le timbre de la voix donc la
hauteur du ton le rythme pour extraire
en fait d expressivité émotionnel
évidemment ce ne sont pas mes nos
émotions qui sont cachés on va détecter
que l'expressivité dont il ya beaucoup
d'autres travaux au multi modalité sur
l'aspect faciale sur les actions et
c'est qu'on va pouvoir détecter aussi
pourquoi on fait ça on fait ça pour
adapter le système à chaque personne
espère qu'il va répondre différemment
alors ces machines voyelles sont tout
sauf émotionnel réellement elle imite
les émotions ya pas de sentiment ya pas
d'émotions n'y a pas d'intention n'y a
pas de désir pas de plaisir pas de
conatus au sens de spinoza n'y a pas de
équilibre de volonté de faire quelque
chose ce ne sont que des imitations que
l'humain a fait mais par contre comment
voit-on réagir en face de ces machines
si au quotidien dans les machines autour
de nous qui jouent des émotions qui avec
lesquels on sera en interaction à ce
qu'elles vont nous isoler des autres est
ce qu'on va être dépendant d'elle
regardez au japon donc cette personne
vit avec une machine qui est un
hologramme donc c'est pas un robot
proprement parler parce qu'ils ne
bougent pas mais c'est un chat box donc
un agent conversationnel voyez c'est
cette espèce de fée clochette qui
pourrait ressembler à un tamagotchi si
vous vous rappelez un peu ces systèmes
elle est là pour lui
donc elle prend soin à la maison et elle
continue toute la journée donc omni
présence de cet objet est donc il ya un
effet d'attachement on voit que la
personne dit je vais rentrer à la maison
l'objet dit tu me manques revient à
travers ces petites
ces petits scénarios qui correspondent
en fait à finalement une interaction
dans le vide puisque la personne en face
il ya une machine
donc on peut imaginer isoler les gens
avec ces objets chez eux et quand on
jeudi qu'il ya effectivement beaucoup de
ces objets de google ou les agresseurs
amazon qui sont achetés à l'heure
actuelle aux états unis et qu'en france
ça commence à démarrer aussi il faut
faire attention
ces machines enregistrons nos
conversations et notre intimité chez
nous et vont les utiliser pour créer des
nouveaux modèles qui vont pouvoir être à
nouveau vendu sous d'autres formes avec
d'autres objets peut-être donc il faut
faire très attention à cette
manipulation possible je travaille aussi
depuis sur l'incitation à faire comment
une machine comme ça qui détecte dans
quel état d'esprit vous êtes peu vous
influencer vous pousser à acheter des
choses que vous auriez peut-être pas
envie d'acheter vous pousser à choisir
différentes stratégies dans votre vie et
qu'ils seront très intrusive
on en est pas encore tout à fait là mais
il faut faire attention donc c'est
arrivé des ces machines sont à la fois
bénéfique pour nous et engendre sa tombe
de risque qui me fait parler de plus en
plus des tic
en tout cas si c'est pas de la
régulation forte c'est un besoin de
comprendre on a besoin dans la société
d'être et avait dit avant de pouvoir
utiliser ces machines qu'on vous
permettre de comprendre mieux nos biais
cognitifs pourquoi on réagit par paresse
pour faire comme le voisin et ses
émotions qui nous anime qui font que
l'on va résonner par intuition sur le
système ans comme le décrit karman prix
nobel donc d'économies en 2012
il écrit deux systèmes le système qui
est intuitif qui est très rapide qui
nous permet de survivre qui est là
depuis très longtemps et le système 2
cognitif qui permet de réguler allons
vers un système 3 2 mais ta connection
cognition pardon où on va pouvoir
finalement être conscient de cette
intuition de cette créativité qu'on peut
avoir tout en ayant compris finalement
il ya d'autres buts c'est un choix qu'il
faut garder l'intuition c'est excellent
pour la créativité l'imagination et dans
certains aspects ont réagi plus vite
avec cette façon d'appréhender les
choses il faut surtout pas qu'on
devienne des machines mais par contre il
faut comprendre qu'elles font quelques l
action derrière sont déterminés
finalement par cette réaction très
rapide je finirai par un point très
positif j'ai eu
ces machines pour aller faire des
enregistrements avec des personnes âgées
dans des ehpad ou à l'hôpital broca avec
des gérontologues les psychologues ont
peu aidé et assisté renforcer les gens
qui perdent la mémoire qui pert langage
grâce à ces machines
on a vu aussi des expériences
extrêmement intéressante avec des
enfants autistes
donc il faut absolument que l'on arrive
à être suffisamment conscients de ce que
font ces machines pour les utiliser au
mieux dans la vie de tous les jours
dernier point attention à une chose en
ce moment ces machines sont fait
majoritairement par des hommes 20% de
femmes font de l'oeil à 80% donc de ces
machines sont faits par des hommes
80% des amis 6e les machines qui sont
faites ont des noms féminins
alexa samantha nadine et cetera ont des
corps de femmes j'ai des voix jeunes et
on va être entouré de ses machines qui
simule finalement des servantes des
assistantes et des rôles subalternes
je pense que sur la représentation des
femmes il ya urgence à dire qu'il faut
faire des machines masculine et féminine
en tout cas on les gens forcément donc
il faudra faire attention à cela et
j'encourage les jeunes femmes à venir
dans ce domaine qui est
pluridisciplinaire ont fait de
l'informatique ne fait pas que ça et la
modélisation en tout cas des émotions
sur machine c'est quelque chose qui
demande de s'intéresser à la psychologie
à la philosophie à beaucoup d'autres
choses
venez sur ces domaines
[Applaudissements]